demasiado ajustado para declarar ganador
el 7 de noviembre del año 2000 los
votantes fueron a las urnas para elegir
al presidente de eeuu sería el
republicano george bush o el candidato
demócrata al golf con las encuestas a
boca de urna incapaces de determinar un
resultado claro la noche de las
elecciones pronto quedó claro que la
presidencia dependía de los resultados
de un estado que toma su primer estado
en el sur gordo obtiene su primera
victoria en nueva inglaterra pero aún no
han declarado victoria ambas campañas se
dicen que quizás la clave de esta
elección es florida tras el recuento
original de votos bush se puso a la
cabeza pero debido al estrecho margen la
ley estatal de florida ordenó un
recuento automático en todo el estado
bush siguió ganando pero su ventaja se
redujo el secretario de estado de
florida lo declaró ganador
la campaña de word tomó acciones legales
para forzar recuentos en un puñado de
condados lo que pensaron que podría
ayudarlos a superar el liderazgo de
muchas máquinas de votación mecánicas
poco confiables que hicieron un agujero
en la boleta hicieron que muchas
papeletas de votación fueran difíciles
de interpretar mientras que en un
condado
distribución poco clara de los boletines
aumentó la confusión una semana después
del día de las elecciones la corte
suprema de florida dictaminó que el
conteo de los votos cuestionables
debería seguir adelante en cuatro
condados después de semanas de disputas
legales para bloquear los recuentos el
tribunal dictaminó que debían continuar
la campaña de buzz presentó una demanda
rápidamente un día después los jueces de
la corte suprema de eeuu dictaminaron
que los recuentos debían detenerse y
luego el 12 de diciembre dictaminó que
no se podían realizar recuentos a tiempo
para cumplir con el plazo federal para
la selección de electores estatales como
resultado george w.bush fue declarado
ganador de las elecciones presidenciales
estadounidenses del año 2000 muchos
demócratas estaban indignados por el
fallo de la corte suprema- señalando el
hecho de que la mayoría de los jueces
eran considerados conservadores y por lo
tanto a favor de bush han pasado 20 años
y la corte suprema de los estados unidos
ha reforzado su mayoría conservadora 6
los nueve jueces son conservadores tres
de los cuales fueron nominados por
donald trump durante la campaña
electoral de este año los demócratas han
expresado sus temores de que se repita
lo ocurrido en florida